here's another thing that proves that
you should feel good about yourselves
and it proves your likability is that
a lot of times when i bring up guests to
this one
because it's you know we're a team here
right just like can you just let me
finish my train of thought without
giving you a [ __ ]
bird right sometimes i'll go i was face
down ass up with my crooked dick on the
floor i'm trying really hard for these
guys
so a lot of times i'll go what about
this person she'll have an opinion
like i don't know you know what i mean
or whatever you know sometimes it's a
good sometimes
but with you it was adamant oh yeah for
sure i love you guys oh really i've been
loving you guys he's so
on he's he's been asleep to you for a
long time he's finally awoke
that's such [ __ ] babe but i hate how
he was like do you guys do you know
jt and chad i'm like you didn't know
them
are you [ __ ] crazy i followed every
watch every single one of your videos of
giving masks to people in huntington
beach
i've watched all of their videos you've
been asleep to them
i'm the real fan no what do you guys
think you guys should ask some questions
to decide who knows you best
oh okay all right where where is he from
which one chad orange county baby
no he's up north he's from san francisco
okay
not a lot of people know that actually
so that proves your actual intimacy with
the situation yeah
you know what by you saying that doughy
because of your eyes
this [ __ ] has no upper lip dog
no i have an upper lip but when i'm
receiving information i kind of
no i looked at you up i sat next to you
during that pod bro i was staring at
your upper lip
the whole [ __ ] time i don't think
your upper lip's bigger than me his is
bigger than yours
yeah but my it's not it's proportional
to my bottom lip
i have a big bottom it's a good point
that's that's the thing it's like
do one or the other yeah what do you
mean
like choose a size you know what i mean
but it's like having one
you know i mean 12 foot sized shoe and
one six foot five
size shoe um it looks weird well i i
think
do you defend your friend yeah okay go
ahead well i think
because what jt was talking about when
he's taking in information yeah his lip
does
curl up because his he's the smartest
guy i know so his noggin is always
computing a lot so
his lip does curl i'm telling you if
you're telling him something when he
when he's listening
it does curl up because he's taking
everything in so deep i'm in processing
mode right now and you can see the
difference yeah
right but when we've gotten close it's
been plump
yeah i want to start saying that all
right so can i
say something to the youtube right now
yeah if i may yeah
i apologize i apologize for
trying to shame you about your thin
upper lip
i didn't know your processes all right i
didn't know that you're processing
information and your lip goes small
and just stop looking at me like that
dodo okay
and i want to say just look at my eyes
though um
sorry and i apologize it'll never happen
again
can i add on to that because i really
appreciate that okay go ahead but i also
think sometimes even though we're chill
guys
confrontation and conflict like that can
lead to a deeper
relationship so i'm grateful for what
happened
like i don't think we'd be as close as
we are now had we not gone through the
upper lip situation
yeah and your willingness to challenge
me and make me better i think it's gonna
lead to you know the future
see this is this is why they win right
they're always positive yeah i mean if
they were in a tragedy
they would figure it out should we give
them tough uh situations to kind of
figure out
yeah chat is like that it's pretty
incredible yes well we actually called
each other after
the podcast and we were like dude that
upper lip situation you're like yeah
that was deep
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah because it made
me wonder like how come other friends
haven't mentioned it
right yeah can i ask you a question
horse tooth
[Laughter]
far away thoroughbred tooth yeah you
know thank you to each his own
but um he's projecting he only has three
teeth left
that's a fact yeah baby you don't you
know i sometimes i feel like
we're not partners we are partners
partners hold each other accountable
they don't did you guys know before i
called you a horse tooth
that i had teeth missing no no there you
go thank you
which teeth are missing all of them from
what
you're just not brushing dude that's
awesome is that tubular badass yeah it's
gnarly huh are they yeah the
implants you got no the ones that you
are all natural it's the ones behind
them i'll show you after the podcast oh
they're completely missing
oh so when your parents would be like
brush your teeth you wouldn't even fake
it you just like [ __ ] that
well i would do it i just would just
don't do the front
yeah right i would just go and then
that's it
well my the background like what's up
what about us you know what i mean
and then eventually like we're gonna
we're leaving
you know you don't give a [ __ ] we're
leaving and they play favorites and then
they come yeah and they pack their [ __ ]
up and then
we're out i don't know where they are
they're probably in this mouth
they've moved into that neighborhood
that's why it looks all horse-like yeah
yeah
wait but did you really get veneers at
14 yeah i got veneers at 14. wait wait
were your
teeth bad back then yeah well i i drink
a lot of soda i eat a lot of popsicles
i got a lot of cavities it's hot out
here babe yeah yeah i mean
you know by the pool just eating
fudgesicles
and uh yeah they're kind of discolored
and small